[Music]
Luke dominate here at the outdoor voice
YouTube channel and we have a perfect
winter project it's cold and snowy out
the boys are home from school because
everything's closed down and I'm gonna
make some benches and some stools the
boys like to hang out with me in the
garage and work on projects I don't
really have a good place for them sit to
sit down I got a couple milk crates and
that's about it so I've got this big
huge piece of aromatic cedar I found and
we found these pieces here check this
out Nate what do you think of that so
I'm gonna try to take these wood rounds
and that plank behind me and see if we
can't make some cool seats for the boys
while they're here in the garage and
just for the heck of it I'm gonna try to
do it without power tools you guys want
to do this with me yeah all right all
right drilling the hole
you're already drilling the hole all
right
how does that look
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
huh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well there we go the cute little stool a
couple things I did learn and I would
have done differently now that I've done
it is I found out that you want to get
the feet to stick out at least as far as
the edge of the seat maybe just a hair
further so you can see on this leg it
does that it's just a little bit sticks
out just maybe a quarter inch further
and this leg does it to this leg not so
much part of that's because we have this
weird shape here but it'll make it less
tippy and this works okay but is a
little bit tippier than a normal round
stool just because of the weird shape
but it's not bad it's it works just fine
and it's just beautiful and now I'm
excited to have Tommy hanging out with
me in the garage a little bit more time
check it out
take a seat yeah yeah it feels Shady
isn't it so you think you may be hanging
out in the garage and sit on your stool
with me a little bit there cool
well guys thanks for watching we hope
you enjoyed this video if you want to
see more great videos from the Anchor
boys YouTube channel don't forget to
like subscribe nailed it
I bye boys